Sheffield saw one of the big upsets of
this election Nick Clegg Liberal
Democrats nineteen thousand seven
hundred and fifty six this was the
moment that Nick Clegg's twelve-year
career as an MP came to an end
Jared o Mara Labour Party 21,000
this heated election caused a rise in
turnout in sheffield hallam and a
healthy portion of those voters were
unusually fired up encouraging young
people to go out to vote has always been
a tricky business during elections but
this time we saw a surge in the number
of 18 to 25 year olds going to the polls
the majority this time put their weight
behind labour Labour's election promise
to scrap tuition fees for new students
went down well here Gary Forrest was
persuaded to vote Labour but Tasha voted
Lib Dem ever since breaks it happened I
think young people have felt the weight
of their vote a bit more I think they've
really realized that they can make a
difference which has been shown in you
know the big young voter turnout and how
it's swung towards labour and I think
the more people realize what they vote
can do the more they've wanted to get
involved with it and the more they want
to change the more they've got involved
in change were you voted conservative
last time yeah what what song it for you
this time when to vote Labour I think it
was just they were lot stronger in what
they were saying in terms of their whole
manifesto this time around
and obviously university fees I've been
to University now I have finished but I
still think it's really big for the
country and that's really you know
really appeal to young people it really
appealed to me there's a huge turnout
here 78 percent turnout a lot of that it
seems is from the youth though and of
course the if the youth have come out
and vote in large numbers the tuition
fees with front and centre
there was a labor surge amongst those
youth votes that's been replicated
across the country and it's played out
here it's not clear why there was a
surge it could have been anger over
brexit or a feeling of not being
listened to but the rise of the youth
vote has been significant in shaping the
outcome of this election Nick Martin Sky
News Sheffield